the Ohio State University is suspending
all fraternities on campus until further
notice the move comes as eleven of the
school's 37 fraternities are under
investigation this semester for code of
conduct violations a majority of the
cases involve hazing or alcohol
Errol Barnett is on Ohio State's campus
in Columbus Erol good morning good
morning
some Buckeyes are stunned by this news
while other students on campus saw this
coming because this is yet another
incident of Greek life being impacted
because of allegations of hazing and
underage drinking now a statement sent
to the chapter presidents from the
University yesterday states that Ohio
State quote will not tolerate behavior
that puts the health and safety of
students at risk indeed this is the
fourth school in two months to ban parts
of Greek life on campus for example on
Tuesday Texas State University
suspended Greek life activities after 19
year-old Matthew Ellis was found dead in
an off-campus apartment alone Monday
Florida State University banned all
fraternities and sororities following
the death of freshman pledge Andrew
Coffey and in September Louisiana State
University suspended its Greek
activities for a month when 18-year old
Maxwell groover died his blood alcohol
level was 0.495 that is more than six
times the legal driving limit and one of
the most high-profile cases is over at
Penn State where 26 paternity members
are facing charges in the hazing death
of Timothy Piazza now here at Ohio State
it's happening at a crucial social time
on campus the last home game of the
season is Saturday students living
inside the fraternities can remain there
while the suspension is in place
sororities remain active Charlie Harrell
thanks